bonjour à tous bienvenue à cet espace
autochtone en direct lendemain du gala
de l'adisq est en fait je veux qu'on
commence tout de suite avec ça on va se
replonger dans une soirée qui a été
formidable pour les autochtones dimanche
dernier on écoute on regarde
je suis content
ce qui d'après midi il nous étonnons mac
et nous aimons nous soyez sans crainte
nous venons un ami
en ce moment historique
on est tous gagnants merci merci à
l'adisq de nous avoir fait cette place
soyez sans crainte
on va la prendre parce que on n'est pas
ici juste parce qu'on est au top tant on
ici aussi parce qu'on est bon
[Applaudissements]
il avait le mot juste vraiment alors je
vous présente mes invités tout de suite
évidemment les abeilles picard notre
habitués de la place bonjour isabelle
louis malys et puis joël rébillard
directrice de musique nomade
bonjour j'aurais d'ailleurs ce n'est pas
la première fois que nous vous
accueillons sur ce plateau
non c'est la deuxième fois et c'est
d'être de retour et il nous manque un
des gagnants parce que florent vollant
l'a dit ils étaient tous des gagnants
c'est florent qui a reçu le félix de
l'artiste autochtone de l'année mais il
l'a bien dit nous sommes tous des
gagnants gagnants d'être sur place la
d'être sur la scène de l'adisq et de
recevoir ce félix pour tous ces gens là
alors chiche à 8 qui devrait arriver
d'un instant à l'autre il est peut-être
pris dans le métro on se bat on va voir
on va l'attendre mais en attendant on va
parler des artistes autochtones parce
qu'il y en avait cinq sur la scène mais
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux joël
mais je sais pas de plus en plus
nombreux montrent qu une meilleure
visibilité de plus en plus on commence à
faire bouger un peu les cartes de
l'industrie aussi pour faire plus de
place à ces artistes là le félix en est
un bon exemple donc j'ai l'impression
que la place se fait puis énormément
d'artistes émergents ou qui sont leurs
pieds qui sont pas de la porte qui
travaille pour pour développer leur
carrière musicale puis nous on sent des
nouveaux à des niveaux de s'être des
nouveaux artistes à tous les vendredis
pratiquement donc c'est une preuve que
ces foisonnent masque en fait depuis que
musique nomade existe en fait ni gamme
wind
au début vous aviez combien d'artistes
sur la plate forme et aujourd'hui vous
êtes rendus à combien mais en fait on
peut pas on peut tout à fait le calcul
est comme ça parce que ni gamme wind la
plateforme d'écouté en continu qu'on a
lancé à l'automne dernier rassemblait
déjà leur répertoire d'artistes qu'on a
rencontrés au fil de nos ateliers en
communauté
donc c'est sûr qu'à chaque année on
rajoute les profils on rajoute une
vingtaine de nouveaux artistes à chaque
année des nouvelles rencontres qu'on
fait en communauté mais l'oeil après 165
170 artistes sur la plateforme
je te dirais qu'on travaille très très
près avec peut-être vingt trente
artistes certains qui ont dit qu'ils ont
des niveaux constamment qui développent
leurs musées qui ont des spectacles chez
des rats donc voyez beaucoup beaucoup
d'artistes a continué 59 mortels
oui alors les artistes autochtones on
les entend de plus en plus j'espère mais
on les entendait ou s'il ya plusieurs
décennies
oui peut-être avec une moins grande
présence je sais pas comment ça
fonctionnait il ya 20 30 40 50 ans ben
en fait ce kiosque fait en sorte qu'on a
commencé à s'intéresser à la musique
autochtone et aux chanteurs ou musiciens
autochtone c'est surtout dans les années
60 70 où il ya eu aussi une
sensibilisation au canada du fai
autochtone donc on voulait savoir un peu
cédé qui lisent autochtone qu'est ce qui
se passait on commence à se faire
entendre à l'isd autochtone
il y avait lancé de l'assemblée des
premières nations qui était la
fraternité des indiens du canada donc
des associations de chefs autochtones
qui étaient mises en place ont commencé
à apprendre la parole donc là la
population s'est aussi intéressée
tranquillement à la musique
il ya eu bien sûr aussi l'avènement des
radios communautaires dans l'est dans
les communautés dans les années 70 ce
week-end en sorte que plusieurs
chanteurs qui ont été ou plusieurs
artistes autochtones qui ont été révélés
d'abord dans leur communauté mais il y
en a quelques uns qui ont qui ont
transcendé les frontières de leur pays
oui on pourrait d'ailleurs parlé de
quelques uns d'entre eux on va rester au
québec en fait parce qu'évidemment il y
en aurait beaucoup à travers le canada
peut être une des plus connues ces
beaufs et sainte-marie d'ailleurs oui
oui alors fait qui est vraiment un icône
là dans le monde musical autochtone mais
au québec aussi il ya plusieurs grands
noms dont philippe mckenzie
oui c'est ça en fait j'ai décidé de vous
faire le top je voulais faire un top 5
des artistes autochtones qui aurait pu
être nommé nommé ou nominés disons avant
mais j'ai pas été capable alors ce
serait top 5 était déjà d'accord ok et
là
et c'est philippe mckenzie qui est un
auteur compositeur interprète qui vient
de malioténam et lui le commencer
l'apprentissage de la guitare à l'âge de
13 ans et l'anecdote elle est absolument
savoureuse il y avait seulement deux
guitares dans la communauté et les
jeunes joie ou ceux qui voulaient
apprendre à jouer de la guitare se
prêtait les guitares donc d'antona gombe
et en deux et une guitare donc lui il va
intégrer à son chant le téwébé gamme
donc il est temps bourg traditionnel
hymne où il va il va vraiment avoir un
son du passé c'est important pour lui de
d'écouter ce qu'elle est les années lui
disais donc de transcender un peu de
cette tradition là à travers sa musique
donc il va faire revivre cet instrument
à travers ses chansons il va mêler le
phoque avec des sonorités un peu plus
traditionnel et c'est ça qui va en faire
un son vraiment unique
il a enregistré au service du nord de
radio-canada trois albums dans les
années 70 et d'ailleurs il y en a un de
ses albums là qu'il enregistre avec
florent vollant un oui et si vous allez
dans un spectacle de fleurs au volant ou
même de caching cet été ils se sont
produits en face du parlement québec
fait toujours le fameux makusham qui
vient de philippe mckenzie donc
notamment donc lui pour lui ça a été
philippe mckenzie c'est une icône au
niveau de la langue de des chats ou des
chansons pop mais en langue innue immune
ça a été les premiers à le faire oui
alors on va refaire un petit peu sur
philippe mckenzie parce qu'en fait c'est
grâce à lui que kashtin s'est rencontrés
dont florent vollant et claude mais
kenzy qui n'est pas parenté avec
philippe
mais c'est grâce à lui qu'ils se sont
rencontrés oui oui effectivement c'est
ce conduit entre autres autour du talent
à l'enregistrement de doris et c'est ça
exactement
et on va tout de suite sur une
parenthèse vers claude mckenzie
parce que autant on entend florent on
l'a toujours entendus au cours des vingt
dernières années autant moment donné
claude a disparu de la scène musicale et
là il revient il revient entre autres
chez musique nomade
oui en fait on enregistrait un nouveau
de 7 l'été dernier on était à sept îles
puis ça a été une rencontre assez
spontané avec lord et on enregistré dans
les studios de la fabrique culturelle
puis il y avait composé une toune
hommage à zachary belfort en faire un
célèbre chasseur de nous et ça a été
vraiment un moment super lap la guitare
on a installé lille
le studio le micro et wendake et fait
soleil villon de tout de suite revu
reconnu la voix de claude sa superbe
voix est aussi son aisance à la guitare
c'est la chanson s'appelle chaque ami
qui est sorti et vendredi dernier puis
un refrain accrocheur il ya de la
douceur beaucoup d'authenticité donc on
a vraiment c'est comme si c'était
vraiment son élément confort la musique
il revient il revient avec son c est
merveilleux donc super but alors que
vous le disiez isabelle il était l'année
passée donc avec avec florent don catlin
a été réunie ça ne veut pas dire que
cache t il renaît mais ça veut dire que
claude mckenzie encore en tant
qu'artiste solo renaît oui en fait j'ai
l'impression que oui ça fait à peu près
je pense près de dix ans ouais que qui
avait rien sorti encore en allemagne
avant un album you à peu près dix ans
donc je peux pas vous en dire plus pour
l'instant mais je crois que ça laisse
présager une chute cette fois ci on
laisse pas et on voit sur facebook à
chaque soir depuis une semaine ses
mélodies au piano mais le distiller
c'est extraordinaire ce que tu fais
vraiment un musicien de grand talent oui
alors il ya des vidéos d'ailleurs
associé aussi à la sortie de sa première
pièce à découvrir avoir wii donkey et
diddy mal enfin qui a fait un vidéoclip
à partir des images d'archivés super
boulot dans les archives de la côte nord
est où et avec zachary bell fort
justement la chanson et on a aussi pris
le moment où on enregistre la chanson
avec l'autre donc l'installation live
tout en simplicité où on le voit
vraiment dans son élément puis je vous
encourage à l'ours est vraiment c'est
très bon retour c'est très très bon ok
alors suivant là on est passé au premier
et puis j'ai dit mais kenzy mais la
seconde vous la connaissez mais
peut-être pour autre chose peut-être que
vous la connaissez pour ça aussi c'est à
l'année sont bonnes ce we know
bien sûr ouais quand même chanteuse tout
à fait que commencer comme ça dont elle
est née aux etats-unis et quand il avait
six mois et les rues déménager dans sa
communauté d'origine
odanak et le passé une partie de son
enfance là où elle a appris entre autres
les contes les légendes de son cousin
bon chez terra et les chants
traditionnels et à l'âge de dix ans sa
famille est déménagée à trois-rivières
et là elle se retrouver un petit peu
tout seul dans cet environnement là en
tant que qu'autochtones oui et elle
s'ennuyait essayer leurs que le
développer le champ entre autres pour
pouvoir se trouver une passion en fait
est là dans les années 50 les déménager
à montréal
elle a étudié les arts etc dans les
années 60 qu'elle veut donner son
premier concert à new york quand même
c'est un bon tremplin pour un beau débat
et elle va faire une tournée au canada
aux états unis et un peu en europe
également
et elle va lancer son son titre qui est
d'après moi ou son disque est le plus
marquant qui la représente le mieux
bouche les dix en 1985
un album qui a été réédité en 2018 web
qui est tellement formidable absolument
absolument je fonçais le jeu à être
nommé el al a dit exactement c'est ce
que je me suis dit oh si oui pourquoi
pas d'ailleurs m'a parfois c'était juste
des questions de recensement c'est qu'il
faut aussi s'il faut se lancer il faut
se prêter au jeu loué des phares son
dépôt de domination s'est beaucoup de
paperasse et beaucoup de ma vie à part
signé par dix épisodes pour dire ça
marche en fait ça veut dire c'est
l'artiste qui dépose sa candidature oui
à l'artiste ou son représentant
indépendant les artistes mais comme dans
tous les cas le concours il ya des
dossiers à être qu'ils vont être évalués
donc chaque artiste doit déposer avec sa
description il ya souvent des lettres
d'entente à faire signer par les
diffuseurs pour prouver que te fais des
spectacles dans l'année pour prouver que
c'est quelque chose qui se passe autour
de ton projet donc je vous interromps
juste pour qu'on garde la belle
boucherie dit oui dans toute sa
splendeur
donc ça voudrait dire qu'elle à nice
elle n'a pas déposé sion dans ce jeu
c'est louise hooper jusqu'il ya aussi
cette étape là à franchir t le prix
c'est une belle étape
on essaie d'ouvrir de créer des ponts
après semaine ya aussi toutes les phares
affaire de marketing musical de sa
volonté son projet
en tant que gestionnaire s'est pas
toujours quelque chose qu'on a le temps
où qu'on connaît ma ruelle n'a pas
vraiment le temps elles viennent réalise
son 53e de fil je pense qu'elle a
tellement d'autres choses à faire est
incroyable dans ce contexte pour les
artistes émergents musique nomade aux
frileux kunming de recensement donc on
monte les dossiers pour les artistes on
essaie justement d'encourager à plus de
dépôt d'artillerie non c'est que c'est
beaucoup de travail puis que ça peut
être ça peut être lors oscille comme
gestion de projet mais alors justement
je vous pose la question est ce qu'il
est ce qu'il plusieurs avaient envie de
le faire ou alors ce qu'il a fallu leur
poussée dans l'eau est ce qu'ils étaient
un peu intimidé non je crois que envie
et là je crois que les artistes avec
lesquels je collabore les raisons dans
lequel je suis tout le monde était super
fier tout le monde tu es super content
après c'est sûr qu'il faut peut-être pas
une actualité dans son projet qui se
passe quelque chose donc ça va peut-être
aussi en projet des artistes à aller de
l'avant avec un projet musical qui était
peut-être sur la glace ou des choses
comme ça mais oui au niveau au niveau de
l'administration c'est toujours un
fardeau supplémentaire et les hauts
niveaux l'intéressent c'était plus de l'
enthousiasme ne s'est pas fait parce
j'ai pas senti que les gens avaient pas
brut et un sujet central était vraiment
de révolution
oui bah tant mieux alors après à l'anis
oui alors je vais vous parler de willy
donne qui est un artiste auteur
compositeur interprète mic mac qui vient
qui est né à lister gauche en fait qui a
grandi en grande partie à montréal et il
va apprendre la guitare de manière
autodidacte aussi à dos laisse
finalement ce qui est intéressant de lui
c'est qu'il va beaucoup faire dans le
country ils vont être inspiré par un
coup nous y sommes c'est notamment qu'on
connaît bien et il va réaliser son
premier court métrage en 1968 qui
s'intitule the ballad of crowfoot avec
le nf et on dit de ce court métrage lors
que c'est le premier court métrage
musical au canada et que ce serait le
précurseur des fameux videopier part où
aller pour ça que je ne tenais
absolument c'est important le souligner
je voulais m'en importante elle fait on
ne sait pas non non
je n'étais pas au courant avant de faire
ch oui et dans ce film là il va aussi
inviter les hôtels du grand bien oui
tout à fait donc on veut éviter les
autochtones à dénoncer mais à s'engager
aussi à faire connaître les causes
autochtone la réalité les enjeux il va
il va s'engager politiquement aussi donc
c'est quelqu'un de quand même vraiment
très très intéressant on dit pour
plusieurs personnes on dit que c'est le
leonard cohen autochtone alors ce n'est
pas rien en effet est-ce qu'il est
décédé aujourd'hui
attendez que je regarde dans mes notes
oui oui il est d'essayer en 2013
ouais ben voilà quelques-uns de ma liste
sont malheureusement décédés le prochain
c'est un cri donc créé you originaire de
mistissini qui s'appelle mon les loulous
que vous connaissez peut-être donc qui
est considéré comme le pionnier de la
chanson faut qu'en languedoc tonnes au
québec
et lui il chantait du phoque en langue
crie et d'ailleurs ça lui valait des
moqueries à dans sa communauté parce que
c'était le premier à faire ça il a
inspiré énormément de gens dont philippe
mckenzie a chanté dans sa langue
il est passé aussi par le fameux collège
manitou mais dans la fin des années 70
dans les laurentides oui et donc il a
été il a été formé par par cet activisme
qui étaient présents ont dit oui dans le
collège même tout donc s'amuser on dit
qu'il aurait style un peu à la mick
jagger donc ça c'est quand même
intéressant c'était c'était vraiment
nouveau mais somme toute il faisait
danser les autochtones soit six heures
on connaît bien la musique
j'aimerais salle n'entendent hui
éventuelle mention si on fait des
recherches à fermer d'autres sites web
associé à radio canada qui s'appelle
c'est un site web documentaire du thé
wiggles à l'électro est donc là ont
retrouvé des extraits et on veut trouver
vraiment où j'en ai sélectionné six mais
oui on a d'abord ri qui est d'accord
donc là on peut le retrouver là louis
oui ok on passe au suivant et elle aussi
bon mais alors je fais un petit tour
chez moi à wayne d'accueil par les deux
chanteurs du bluesman en fait c'est
comme ça qu'on pourrait le décrire
gilles sioui qui est un artiste qui est
décédé
environ deux ans si je me trompe pas
mais c'est un artiste autochtone de
grand talent qui est très reconnue au
québec
il a notamment travaillé avec kevin
parent il a travaillé avec achten donc
il a travaillé avec plusieurs grands il
a commencé sa carrière en 1974 dans
leurs caisses de son frère et à la fin
des années 70 déjà il se promenait de
bar en bar pour interpréter des succès
de jimi hendrix notamment donné aux
lionnes donc c'était vraiment son
univers son style et au début des années
90 il veut monter le trio sauf rennes il
va accompagner qu'à chine pendant
plusieurs concerts ont tourné notamment
il va fonder également le groupe
midnight riders dans les mêmes années 90
que connu quand même un beau succès dans
la région de québec et au québec
il a participé à l'enregistrement d'une
cinquantaine d'albums donc c'est pour
rien avec de nombreux chanteurs et
autres artistes québécois oui docteur ès
que quand il se présentait sur la scène
il se présentait en tant qu'autochtones
c'est quelqu'un qui était très réservé
un pour l'avoir vu à quelques reprises
donc moi je les ai vus dans des concerts
de lui même ça c'est sûr que c'était on
le sentait on le savait dans la
communauté ou autre mais à l'extérieur
jolivet avec kevin parent et non se
présentait pas nécessairement de cette
façon le mont le savez nous à l interne
mais bon les musiciens c'est rare qu'on
leur tend le micro de touristes et c'est
toute la guinée bissau du mans et là on
l'entend plus
non tu as ta retraite mais en fait il
est décédé
depuis c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'au
visite à la fête désormais commencé il
ya deux ans environ
oui mais on est encore dans la
communauté sont en chemin et puis s'en
sent riffs de guitare on le connaît ah
oui oui qui sont les les jeunes artistes
qui l'ont suivi dans la communauté
tu me connais à wendake et oui oh mon
dieu c'est une bonne casse les oreilles
parce qu'en fait je regardais bon qui
était sur la scène de l'adisq dimanche
dernier catherine ou unis nous keeway
catherine où on peut imaginer que
l'héritage de florent et de claude
mckenzie a été très important et les
autres y sont chez les oui je me suis je
me suis dit voilà la question m'a
cherché les mots akossi j'ai vécu
pendant six ans et demi quelques-uns
chez les mots rock qu'on connaît comida
est beau c'est son nom qui est un
guitariste aussi de renom qui accompagne
et jonas pendant longtemps donc il y en
a quand même quelques-uns qu'on connaît
mais c'est vrai que la relève comme moi
elle est ce que les étiquettes mais qui
ont une âme bien née
oui mais je prédis que ça va quand même
évolué c'est sûr mieux c'est sûr que le
clown ou sexy ça fait longtemps il ya
quelque chose qui s'est passé du haut en
bas donc il ya des jeunes oui oui mais
non mon nom d'artiste un peu partout
attikameks comme ceux dans les
communautés oui mais qu'en ce moment ça
ça crée énormément muse et mica mac avec
kwanten condos oui donc je prédis quand
même plus de relève pour moi pour
l'année prochaine et prochain fils ex
pilote je crois qu'il va y avoir une
diversité de plus en plus grande
je laisse ma réussite donc si je
comprends bien sûr le site denis gadoury
ne sera pas une fois par mois ça va être
une fois par semaine oui mais oui
iaquinta donc mac il ya des arcs cesse à
kahnawake en ce moment où c'est qu'ils
écrivent beaucoup
il y un avenir qui osent jq icg a
remporté le titre deux auteures
compositrices interprètes autochtones de
l'année de l'animation se tient cette
année avec son premier titre you leur à
nico et qui a dit qu'un mec égalisa bd
cela justement par le partage de sa
longue également une rotation oui je me
trompe donc c'est sûr que c'est des arcs
cisco com envisage éventuellement monter
sur wii est ce qui nous en restait un
service apprécié et un groupe à
et ce n'est pas le moindre vous avez
jeté les danses parler de ce groupe qui
est devenue salle où est le groupe
saluer joola les brise légère hybride et
hybride
donc c'est un groupe rock des années 70
qui ont commencé donc au nunavik au nord
du québec et il ya différents musiciens
à travers le toit qui ont fait partie de
ce groupe là dedans elisapie
exceptionnelle qui est originaire de
saint louis joos absolument est ce que
c'est un groupe qui leur est inspirée
enfin qui bouillonnait de leur vie à
l'ewi que ça revient quand elle craint
notamment son dernier album et l'aurait
écouté différentes choses dans ce
groupe-là janisson notre faim donc ça
c'est intéressant très populaire dans
les années 70 dans les années 80 il ya
fait des tournées bien sûr dans le
milieu inuit mais bien au-delà de ses
frontières là et le nord du québec est
quand même moins de luanda qui je me
souviens de ce groupe là quand j'étais
jeune donc ça le vraiment c'est d'aller
au delà des frontières du faitout et un
groupe intéressant actuellement inspiré
par les beatles par jimi hendrix aussi
donc voilà en guise l'univers de faire
alors je rappelle à nos gens qui nous
suivent évidemment qu'ils peuvent aller
commenté sur la page facebook on étend
facebook live en ce moment donc à les
commenter dit tu nous tiens justement
quel artiste autochtone vous connaissez
et sinon quel artiste autochtone vous
aimez aussi que vous aimeriez voir plus
présent sur la scène musicale québécoise
ou canadienne ou internationale
d'ailleurs ça me fait penser que on
avait invité le gagnant florent vollant
mais florent est occupée l'état
malioténam aujourd'hui et puis ce
n'était pas possible pour lui d'être
présent avec nous aujourd'hui on avait
invité elisapie j'en profite pour le
dire elle ne peut pas être là
aujourd'hui mais elle sera en tournée la
semaine prochaine alors si vous êtes à
paris
vous allez pouvoir la voir
elle va en france et en suisse donc je
pense qu'elle devait être très occupée
ces jours ci alors on la laisse
travailler se préparer pour pour partir
en tournée on a fait le tour de nos
sénateurs
oui c'est mentionné florent vollant
moi j'ai trouvé ça extrêmement
intéressant aussi de voir florent gagné
ce félix là pour moi c'est un retour du
balancier parce qu'il faut pas que le
groupe qui achetaient n'a été
complètement évacué des ondes radio et
de tous qui nomine à sion prix après la
crise d'oka oui alors qu'ils étaient au
sommet absolument il venait de commencer
leur carrière depuis 89 je pense que cet
engin
le premier est de 80 donc ça a été ça a
été fulgurant ça a été mal vu et tout
d'un coup on ne les voit plus donc pour
moi que c'est que florent et gagner ce
fait dès que cela c'est un symbole qui
était absolument important oui il le
fait qu'il ait fait monter avec lui tous
les nommer c'était la bonne idée d'aller
wilson humain mais il ya eu donc c'est
des gagnants autochtone dans cette
catégorie artiste autochtone de l'année
non les a pas vus dans les autres
catégories
je crois qu'ils s'appuient wii qui était
dans le premier cas la roulette qui
était inquiété dans gala hors d'onde que
ça pour elle dans une langue autre que
le français
oui comme ça le wind waker l'angoissé
mais sinon le ce soir là on n'a vu
personne d'autre dans les autres
catégories
ce soir l'enjeu le dimanche le dimanche
lorsque ces terres je représentais grand
public là elisapie je crois qu'elle
était dans quelque temps nous deux mais
moi j'aurais dit oui mais parce que je
repense à kashtin kachine était à
l'adisq c'était pas pour l'artiste
autochtone de l'année à cette époque-là
390 à l'automne 90 qu'ils ont gagné en
pleine crise d'ailleurs dont 790 ok
voilà où c'était en 90 et il avait gagné
en fait dans deux catégories je vais
regarder je veux mettre mes lunettes
pour pour le retrouver j'ai indiqué
l'information il avait reçu huit
nominations au gala remportant les félix
du microsillon comme on disait
boc un microsillon country fauqué
premier disque de l'année est donc
vraiment très intéressant mais c'est
vrai qu'après on les a pas vraiment
beaucoup vu nécessairement et comme on
avait reçu à l'émission kathia rock oui
elle nous disait que c'était difficile
pour les artistes autochtones étant
donné qu'il chantait pour la plupart
dans une langue autochtone
oui et depuis que la catégorie créée
autre langue le français
oui mais il est s il devait nommer ou
nominés et d'envoyer la donc c'était
plus difficile pour pour eux d'accéder à
au grand galop film
oui c'est une des raisons c'est pour
laquelle ont élaboré le félix de
l'artiste autochtone de l'année pour
adapter aussi certains certaines normes
certains cadres pour que ce soit plus
réaliste pour me jean d'assé sont eux
bien sûr il y encore la possibilité de
s'inscrire dans les albums folk album
pop mais son nom reste de l'année et
c'est sûr qu'il ya la question du
français là mais je croyais quand même
aussi un équilibre ce qui est passé mais
tout ça évolue aussi énormément donc au
moins avec ce magnifique cela on a une
ouverture supplémentaire mais ces
bourses que fellah 10 parce que c'est la
différence
ils ont et montrer la différence entre
égalité et équité
en fait tout le monde qui conçoit
d'origine chinoise ou latinos ou
québécois où on peut avoir accès à la
liste n'ont pu être nommés sont ils la
bonne musique est vraiment mais disons
que les autochtones des fois on part
d'un peu plus loin pour plein de raisons
la langue la distribution à la
reconnaisse ce match était donc là en
amenant sa au premier plan comme ils
l'ont fait ils ont ils ont permis une
équité je trouve entre les autochtones
et les absolument critique et non pas
plusieurs comme nautiques sont
anglophones ou six personnes s'adonnant
c'est un défi de vis supplémentaire de
la fed est automatiquement remis dans la
sélection autres langues ou anglophone
puis après ça le reste c'est pas c'est
pas accessible mais oui alors c'est
dommage en fait que chaoui t'es pas là
on ne le voit pas arriver il est
peut-être encore pris dans le métro
j'espère que non pour lui mais s'arrêter
fin de l'entente parce que on parlait
tout à l'heure donc dû des lendemains de
la crise d'oka ça a été difficile donc
pour les artistes
les radios privées les ont évacués de
leur programmation mais est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont beaucoup plus
présents dans les radios privées
j'entends à québec
j'entends matthew sa jalousie non les
grandes radios quand même j'entends - à
montréal ça c'est certain que moi ça
dépend quand je me promène rouge et on
veut les entendre davantage évidemment
on se promène sur la côte nord mais
c'est pas dans les radios communautaires
et autochtones mais qu'il a dans les
matières principales
oui absolument il n'y a pas encore de
quotas pour les musiques ou les langues
autochtones en 28nm très brillant mais
pour le français pour lier artistes
francophones nous et rémy il faut que ça
reste ainsi mais je crois que il faut
développer des quotas pour les artistes
et les langues autochtones dans un
contexte commercial
c'est extrêmement important c'est pour
la sauvegarde des langues qui pour faire
de la place à 10 à ces artistes là aussi
qu'ils ont été évacués d'une industrie
qu'on a construit sans eux donc ils sont
et je crois que ça se travaille en ce
moment qu'il ya des démarches qui se
font des premières démarches auprès de
la cftc qui se font pour pour aller dans
ce sens là ok mais aussi c'est toujours
extrêmement difficile dans tous les cas
pour un artiste d'être joué sur les
radios commerciales
ça prend 10 de ce très bon chez pop il
faut qu'on rentre dans des critères le
thé grand public
oui ceci dit les artistes qui
autochtones qui joue dans ce style là
qui sont encadrés comme matthew ou
chaoué tous une chance mais c'est
énormément de travail où c'est encore
une fois c'est une question de marketing
et de celle de style musical ceci dit
sur tout ce qui est radios
communautaires aux radios universitaires
on semble moi je le ressens énormément
fait l'intérêt de beaucoup beaucoup de
retours les gens sont contents quand
même ailleurs dans le monde des radios à
londres par exemple vous êtes désigné
des gens qui m'écrivent qui reçoivent
nôtre qui nous en redemande fait que
cette ouverture lakic est présent
partout réel après seulement dix côté
puis du style musical ça c'est c'est
égal pour te ment l'affection est pas
facile et pas besoin d'être dans ce soit
je la vois dans ces régions est un
artiste autochtone aujourd'hui le 15 à
16 ans comme ce qu'on a vu
les philippe mckenzie le monde qui veut
faire de la musique à ce qu'ils font aux
qui vont y est ce qu'ils peuvent cogner
à votre partenaire safran oui oui
musique nomade en fait je refais le
porter non c'est une bonne idée
on y connu pour les ateliers confiant
comme notez donc chaque année on va
aller dans certaines communautés
dépendamment des gens qui nous
contactent parce qu'ils ont des projets
ils veulent enregistrer et on voit
s'installer de semaine on va monter des
studios on arrive avec uniquement des
réalisateurs musicaux et vidéo et ils
ont enregistré les chansons avec les
gens donc ça peut être souvent c'est une
porte d'entrée community être une
nouveauté mais c'est d enregistrement
professionnel de très belles qualités sa
vie avec des vidéos et on est tous ces
professeurs qui sont qui sont promus sur
une gamme wind ce qui fait en sorte
qu'un artiste peut importe son niveau
peu importe si t'en kadri ya ce
profileur du peu utilisé pour se
présenter pour faire entendre sa musique
sa biographie ses photos ses vidéos ecce
terra en fait de plus en plus de projets
ponctuels avec des artistes qui nous
contactent pour des enregistreurs
enregistrement d'albums complets
donc on va les encadrer dans la demande
de subvention parce qu'encore une fois
il ya des étapes à suivre pour être
capable de réussir développer une
carrière en musique
donc on va encadrer les artistes dans
l'amont et subventions dans le
développement dans la direction
artistique comment comment quel état on
prend pour réaliser un album donc sont
le fait de plus en plus avec des
artistes
donc oui ces artistes là ont le droit de
nous contacter au même titre que tous
les artistes émergents et pour avoir de
l'encadrement pour produire avec musique
nomade puis on est ouvert à tous tous
les types de projets en fait aux yeux
rien d'une carte son poste fixe donc je
dirais qu'on développe de plus en plus
de collaboration de d'artistes qui nous
contactent qui ont des idées qui veulent
collaborer avec d'autres artistes puis
on se déplace dans le territoire donc
tout est possible il faut avoir la
volonté il faut être prêt faut avoir des
projets et voulons y mettre l'énergie
puis on va être le prochain cadre ici et
est ce que vous sentez que il ya plus de
deux musiciens ou d'artistes émergents
qui proviennent des communautés par
lesquels vous avez pas assez par rapport
aux autres
l'on sent ce qu'on essaie de faire c'est
de retourner aussi au même endroit on
sent qu'il n'y ait vraiment fort qui
sait les artistes avec lesquels on
collabore on lire voit plusieurs fois
hélas apparaît puis le message passe
aussi donc oui j'ai quelque chose
sur le par rapport au territoire quand
on visite qui se créent un réseau mais
on essaie de on essaie de faire d
ancrage solide puis une fois qu'on sent
qu'il ya une certaine il ya quelque
chose qu'ils veulent on peut être aller
par d'autres artistes qui nous
contactent puis mais là on peut pas être
partout mais des contacts partout et
qu'on essaie vraiment de
on essaie que ce soit durable que ce
soit pérenne que ce soit pas diffusée
pas et ces moments le pic les artistes
qui vont collaborer avec nous ce qu'ils
ont envie d'aller de l'avant mais qu'on
puisse les suivent puis que ce soit une
démarche sérieuse qui va créer une
baisse de taux nominaux en développement
de mieux en mieux alors fait musique
nomade est une création du wapikoni
mobile
on va le rappelez vous cette création de
manon barbeau ont détruit 2 à woippy
connu exactement vous fonctionne un peu
sur le même principe avec votre roulotte
en ambulants on a beau nos colonnes ceci
dit oui c'est un idiot
oui on prend mais c'est le principe de
se déplacer problème parmi ces sahraouis
la smm embargo qui a fondé wapikoni
mobile et musique moment oui donc c'est
oui c'est exactement passé on dit qu'on
est la petite cousine 6 ou à la vanille
mais ça a tellement évolué maintenant
une musique nomade est un organisme à
part entière ç'a tellement il va lui et
que maintenant on sent vraiment la
différence et tous m'ont collaboré très
proches collaborateurs on est on est
dans les mêmes bureaux donc c'est sûr
que le lien naturel mais est ce que vous
vous promenez dans les cinquante cinq
communautés du québec où vous allez au
delà de ça ce que vous allez ailleurs au
canada est ce qu un peu comme le
wapikoni vous allez à l'étranger aussi
ça on n'a pas fait un enregistrement à
l'international notre réseau et surtout
au québec
oui puis parce qu'en fait les artistes
du québec ont ce besoin de ce sport là
par rapport par sion cette ce double
combat d'être artiste autochtone mais
artistes québécois en territoire
canadien aussi une compétition il
quelque chose qui est difficile où c'est
à ce niveau là
mais on va on ignorait que vous empêche
d'aller ailleurs on va dentelle en
ontario souvent on est allé dans les
maritimes à plusieurs reprises on a un
très très grand réseau d'artisans et
maritimes beaucoup temps beaucoup
d'ateliers de co-création donc très
proche collaborateur d'humanisme aussi
donc on se déplace on peu partout c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment selon les
projets puis la vision le de donner à
l'autre on fait des choix oui elle rompt
pourrait en profiter pour parler des
prochaines sorties parce qu'il ya quand
même plusieurs artistes là vous disais
il y en a chaque vendredi il y avait il
y avait claude et je voyais sur votre
liste que vous m'avez envoyé en a
plusieurs autres on pourrait en parler
oui et depuis la rentrée culturelle en
fait on commençait la rentrée culturelle
avec l'album ni té i am i win qui est un
album de compilation justement des des
escales qu'on a fait une dernière en
fait à l'été dernier à manawan et à sept
îles pour les communautés où à chaque
minute énorme oui donc ça ça combine dix
titres d'artistes émergents ou
d'artistes qu'on connaît bien comme ça
guy ottawa par exemple qui fait une
collaboration avec la jeune oie ce donc
ses 10 titres originaux des nouveaux
titres d'artistes attikameks qui nous
qu'on a accompli sur un album qui est
absolument magnifique beaucoup folk pop
indie donc liste d'albums leur
convenance et très très bien fonctionné
ce qui permet de découvrir les univers
variés vraiment a dit camille qui nous
permet de découvrir des artistes qu'on
ne connaît pas comme meego natthawut qui
fait un un blues avec des chants
traditionnels très très puissant et qui
même à manawan les gens savaient peu
qu'elle chantait puis l'ont découverte
grâce à cet atelier le puits donc c'est
très très beau on est sorti le premier
ep de 40 pilotes fontaine que vous
connaissez sûrement oui je crois que
l'était quand même sous le radar on
attendait avec les gars sortent quelque
chose tu as les deux maillots un cari
également et trèbes aussi un pop indie
c'est très doux très authentique on sent
que les soirs boulet où ça tient ou ça
je presse pam en français avec avec un
peu de nous extrêmement rouge je pense
que c'est une artiste à surveiller puis
c'est un début c'est trois de ces trucs
qui s'écoute vraiment tout seul est très
intéressant on a sorti un album des
maritimes justement du groupe a lancé
wendell thunder mais qu ils font
je dirais rock psychédélique on revient
dans une nouvelle voie peu des années 70
cdc des musiciens aguerris on les
connaît énormément dans les maritimes
ils sont connus il joue depuis toujours
mais on revient vraiment dans cette
espèce de votre psychédélique mais
mélangé avec des chants et des tambours
traditionnels mic mac c'est très
intéressant très puissant ça c'est un
vote blanc comment aux amateurs des
années 70 on est gros plus dans la vague
woodstock mais dans un dans une façon
contemporaine est à la fois
traditionnels parce que l'on garde des
éléments spécifiques à la culture c'est
très intéressant également que je me
pendant les sorties la semaine prochaine
aux sciences en sang le nouveau titre de
queen tiger lillies jack et pinsky qu'on
avait présentée lors de notre concert
annuel l'été dernier donc c'est un dieu
qui est attendue aussi kwanten tangol
font un mélange de chants de gorge inuit
et de blues electronic arts est beau il
y disait keynes qui vous la connaissez
peut être elle aussi un univers très
rock cinématographique qui ont écrit une
chanson ensemble qui s'appelle senio qui
va sortir vendredi prochain c'est très
beau très intéressant on a dit van et 86
un peu propice csu pas c'est vraiment
une rencontre d'univers qu'on ne peut
pas la chance d'entendre souvent je te
disais tout à l'heure quelques winton
qui nous allons fêter tout vous avez le
suisse exactions sort un nouvel album
aussi à la fin du mois donc elle est pop
aux causes toujours revendicateurs y est
toujours là pour se battre pour les
jeunes pour les femmes noté way beaucoup
c'est de collaboration sur ce nouvel
album love
alors je le dis encore pour les gens qui
nous suivent parce que je sais qu'il ya
de plus en plus qui nous suivent à
l'international on voit dans les
commentaires qui surgissent l'asu la
page de notre diffusion en direct on est
loin des chants traditionnels
autochtones et ça c'est important de le
dire la musique a tellement évolué dans
cet univers là aussi vraiment on a des
surprises incroyables
on mélange beaucoup je pense à
l'identique on connait bien oui oui un
artiste mal et 7 et lui ce qu'il a fait
c'est qu'il est allé faire ses
recherches au musée canadien l'homme
donc musée l'histoire oui dans les
archives pour essayer de retrouver des
vieux chants mêlés 7 puis il leur lance
à l'assaut sera s'en prennent avec de
l'électro avec écoute c'est passionnant
manifestement dangereux c'est un bon
moyen de faire d'actualiser finalement
la culture et la transmettent d'une
certaine manière mais autrement exact je
constate toujours sait aussi que les
chants traditionnels
elle tombe au traditionnel séder son cd
musique complètement actuelle ces
maudits folklore donc c'est pas y'a pas
en avant puis après nos yeux des jeunes
des communautés qui reprennent les
chants traditionnels parce qu' en droit
en vie puis il ya des développements des
supports sol c'est benoît qui qui font
le tour n'est pas au sens communauté
donc c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
actuelle et ça se marie très bien avec
d'autres ajustements contemporain et
lyon c'est vrai qu'on le voit de plus en
plus et le public aime ça parce que ça
surprend c'est de la découverte en même
temps puis oui et ça c'était ma dernière
question qui est le public justement
parce que à l'adisq évidemment ce sont
des gens du milieu qui choisissent les
autochtones qui vont être nominé mais le
public ce qui va le public qui va dans
les spectacles qui est-il autochtone
autant que non autochtone public ça
dépend en histoire à montréal
je dirais que c'est yaya unieux le
réseau qui va être souvent au rendez
vous que les gens se connaissent qui
vont essayer de d'aller dans les mêmes
dans l'est dans les vernissages dans les
lancements ont rencontré les mêmes
personnes qui sont le soin je crois que
là où il ya un problème c'est que les
artistes qui viennent et communauté
qu'on est capable de faire tourner ou de
développer une carrière musicale a vécu
et qui vont tourner dans les réseaux de
diffuseur ce qu'on a passé le réseau
dans les communautés je pense que c'est
un besoin qui se trouvent pour aller
vers les artistes en fête des
communautés par exemple leur indique où
il va jouer partout au québec louis mais
va pas jouer en communautés partout au
québec
et là c'est là que ce serait intéressant
pour qu'ils les allées les gens en
adoptant des communautés puissent avoir
accès à ces mêmes cela en fait puis
découvrir les nouveautés musicales il ya
ce qui se passe - j'ai l'impression mais
je sais pas si c'est toute cette
impression l'eau et isabelle ya quand
même un petit réseau mais c'est souvent
les mêmes personnes qu'on voit les mêmes
chanteurs
ça serait intéressant de voir le côté
émergentes davantage un peu partout dans
les communautés effectivement souvent ça
va se passer dans les festivals de
musique ou dans les parois où ils ont
volé voire davantage mais l'heure de
l'année c'est vrai qu'on les voit pas en
dehors de ça ce qui se passe avec les
concerts jetons comme binghamton mtn
conséquent présente chaque année où les
collaborations on parle du mx2 de chants
traditionnels avec des sons
contemporains savons chercheurs un plus
grand public aussi le pays collaboration
qui le mix des genres
ça permet d'aller capter l'attention
d'un public qui n'était pas
nécessairement rendez vous pour les
musiques pour les oies autochtone plus
avoir capté l'attention de ce public là
bas que j'ai l'impression que le public
est grandissant dans tous les cas il
faut continuer d'y rentrer au fur et
mesure isartis ou s'ils se dévoile oui
alors on se laisse avec deux suggestions
quotas d'artistes pas tant d'artistes
autochtones pour les entendre sur les
radios privées
et puis un réseau qui se développe dans
les communautés parce que c'est
important de voir tous les artistes
émergents tous les artistes déjà
implanté il y en a il y en a beaucoup je
pense qu'on pourrait aller voir un
spectacle tous les soirs vous ne savez
cris des dépenses neemia entre les
nations qui sont qui se connaissent pas
toujours non plus en train donc ses
besoins oui oui merci à toutes les deux
merci à shawi votre verre d'eau vous
attend encore laissera merci beaucoup la
semaine prochaine on va parler de
littérature
alors isabelle je vous attend sur ce
plateau et je vais en discuter mais ces
verrous joël rebière merci infiniment on
ira visiter évidemment la plateforme
ligaments wind écouter surtout oui et
surveiller le facebook parce que c'est
vraiment le consort les nouveautés à
chaque semaine au site
absolument merci merci à vous les deux
merci à vous et bien sûr à la semaine
prochaine pour un autre rendez vous des
espaces autochtone en direct au revoir
[Musique]